I take it you've heard the name Abraham
brand they call him the preacher I
believe he resides hang on her body
isn't turning up near the river find out
the root of these killings time is of
the essence what brings y'all there swag
so I smoked thought would see some
lodgings rest our horses you need to see
the preacher
we have new yes welcome to Mount Hermon
how long will you be staying long enough
to rest few days
Abraham frightens me David you are in
search of something
but some strange twist of fate
Abraham Simon killed my father to me
years ago David you will kill this man
you're not safe I tried to leave this
place
they say he's been touched by God
they're free
you're not feeling well no if you're
fine
no now you have the fever she's not
right tre sure you have no idea what's
going on here
I'm a Texas Ranger I was sent by the
governor himself thought it chasing this
man my entire life
are you through my wife
heathens be damned say one word I'll
blunt head off
he's pursuing the river thank you did
your father
take it I've known you'd be coming for
me David
I'm guessing you didn't foresee this you
know boy my head your name is Bill Pope
you're an intelligence officer the CIA
his daughter